let's go next to our caller from the
for15 area code caller from for15
what's your name and what's on your mind
today hey David this is Reggie I'm
calling from Santa Cruz area oh great
what's going on so I was kind of curious
listened to your show a lot and kind of
during the aoc coverage at one point he
sort of talked about maybe we could find
or hold out for like stronger candidates
but my thought was kind of like at this
point kind of given the challenges of
getting people up and running and
getting all the political majorities we
need to win as progressive candidates it
seems like the real talent that we need
to care about is actually organization
and messaging and more than like
knowledge which it feels like something
you can sort of grow over time on
there's a couple different things in
there so first first and foremost I've
expressed my concerns we were talking
about this in the studio earlier this
week which is now that we've seen a
number of interviews from this sort of
new wave of progressive and leftist
candidates now that I've interviewed
more of them including earlier this week
and last week in the week before I am
concerned because a lot of the people
that are running don't really know very
much and fall apart under the most
simple pushback and questioning and
that's really scary to me and the reason
that it's scary is not so much because
we have to make a choice between
knowledge and organization the reason
that it's scary to me Reggie is that the
right has already shown how they can
reduce the level of debate to someone
liked by someone or to allow someone
like Donald Trump to be considered a
legitimate elected official I don't want
to see the left do an equivalent or
analogous thing which is under the guise
of they have the right look or the right
way of talking or they've taken three
policy positions that even though they
don't really understand
they they fit what we now want and
allowing people who don't really know
stuff and think critically about
solutions to get into positions of power
we can debate like is that better than a
Republican well yeah in a lot of cases
it's still better than a Republican but
what my concern is and it's not just
Alexandria Acacio Cortez it's a lot of
the people that have won Democratic
primaries it's that they fall apart in
terms of the real understanding about
economics health care whatever under
just basic questioning and that's not
good for anybody over the long term
yeah I just feel like that's something
that we can train them to be good at but
as long as they're not taking corporate
tax money and things like that we can at
least trust that they are that their
hearts in the right place you know and
if they're organizing is strong
sometimes they can just overcome yeah
well Reggie let me play devil's advocate
if you said if someone's not taking
corporate PAC money we can trust that
their money that their heart is in the
right place if somebody calculated that
in total they would raise more money by
not taking corporate PAC money would
that be an example of how not taking PAC
money is not so much about their heart
being in the right place but just making
a calculated decision um yeah I mean
that's certainly fair but I think we
just we we have these metrics to like
help us understand whether there are
conflicts of interest and you're sort of
like there's there's only so much that
we can do to make sure that we have sort
of a borderline level of trust and yeah
because we're sort of fighting such an
uphill battle I feel like we need to
kind of give a little bit of leeway and
just kind of push people who are already
community leaders up and really just
sort of like give them what we can give
them and try and just hope that they you
know I mean that's just where I'm coming
from that's a lot of hoping and and and
faith in that things go right I mean
listen I generally agree with you I
guess I just want to be cautious about I
I wouldn't ever say any candidate who
does X we know that that we can trust
and whether it's not taking corporate
PAC
that's an equivalent to listen I'm a
religious Christian any candidate that's
against abortion I can trust to do the
right thing any statement like that when
we're dealing with elections and elected
officials I want to be skeptical of and
really think critically about that's all
I'm saying yeah yeah that's probably
fair okay good all right well thank you
for the call appreciate it very very
important issues being brought up I
don't think we fundamentally disagree I
think it's just sort of like a matter of
degrees yeah you said we should train
the candidates and she'll learn more as
they take off and yeah but these are
internships right these are internships
I'd rather see them trained before they
decide I totally agree with you